[Applause]
all right lift your numbers
okay 321
bingo
I won hello hello Charlie I'm Gemma
gracewood from letterboxed uh and
your book
and now your film
have brought so much meaning uh and and
a language for parents like me with
young children to explain
anxiety and fear and loneliness and I
was wondering who you are with an
Academy Award it's incredible
um what are the stories especially on
film that have been as meaningful to you
as yours is to us
you mean what are the stories I've heard
from people about the film they've uh
about no I mean films films and growing
up in your life anything that brought
you
yeah and well like the black stallion
was massive for me
I just love that this kind of
resurrected relationship you know the
extraordinary
journey of a horse
um
yeah you know I think I read more books
and watched things Tintin and Asterix
and
um Edward artisani wrote books about a
boy called Ten but they're all very
um
you know he went into their world and I
did find a lot of Solace and Carmen
books definitely when I read them
um yeah I'm sorry I'm not more I don't
get out of the way
um Charlie and I met about 30 years ago
and we almost immediately bonded over a
film called spinal tap and we've I guess
we've talked every day since and every
day since we've
come up with numerous quotes from spinal
tap and in fact the name of our
production company is none more
Productions and our suits are none more
black so so
not on the emotional side but certainly
on the Friendship side that's been a a
piece of cultural glue
yeah I think just thinking about your
question
um uh I just want to say that the
problem awards are incredible and I'm
speechless to be truthful but it's
almost as as greater award has been the
responses from people to me about their
reaction to the book and the film for
instance um someone told me the other
day that she said that her five-year-old
grandson looked up at her when they were
shopping and she said that he's learned
every single sentence in the film and uh
he looked up at her and said Gran you
know you're enough just as you are you
know that and she looked down at him and
stopped and realized she'd never
understood that or ever thought that and
she said that I was listening to my
grandson was telling me he's five that
I'm enough as I am and she said she had
in a street she had put tears pointed
down my face and not just for her
realization but also for that for that
fact that she knew that he would for the
rest of his days have these words going
through him and that for me is gold you
know
yeah
okay next that doesn't answer your
question does it next up we have 142
before we move over to the virtual Press
Room hi over here I'm Maureen Lee Linker
from Entertainment Weekly
um I'm Maureen I want to know more about
your dog what is their name who's
looking after them in the hotel to tell
us
he's called Barney and he's a miniature
dachshund long-haired and he actually is
the mole he he's the mole is the only
creature in the film that isn't really
like a mole in real life so the boy is
from you know it's the mole and he is
really a reflection of my dog he's very
he's very hungry greedy and he's with my
friend Louisa who's looking after him
yeah and I I I to be truthful I hadn't
been on an airplane for 18 years until
the Oscars because I yeah I just hadn't
and so leaving him he's 15 I felt
terrible leaving him
um but anyway so that's my dog yeah and
also Matthew has a dog called Vincent
um he loves just as much to answer your
question
all right next up we'll be moving to our
virtual Press Room with Lusa news agency
and then our final
be from 385. so Lusa news agency Europe
hi uh congratulations on the win I am in
the virtual world so you're not seeing
me yes uh so this this was an amazing
year for animation
um but all your fellow nominees
um uh also had very interesting
approaches so we'll shout out for
Portugal because I love ice Merchants
too so what do you think animation
conveys that is so unique
um that you know other films cannot do
like what is it about animation that
that is is so creative and and uh
conveys so much emotion
I think I think you you can do anything
with with animation draw anything move
anything change anything uh it's it's a
sort of a massive landscape of
possibility
um and I'm you know this is my first
film I mean I got involved and
co-directed it
um but you know it was such a journey
for me learning about this uh and the
the other the other films are
extraordinary
um I loved watching them and I I met all
of them actually one of the brilliant
things about being in the Oscars is
meeting other filmmakers and talking
about their films and the animators are
just extraordinary
um
yeah does that answer question
doesn't matter oh
it doesn't matter
um yeah thank you thank you sorry
it's Jazz 10K from variety hello
congratulations to you both from the win
um Isabelle wallabridge did such an
incredible job with the score talk about
what made her the perfect composer for
the boy the marble fox so Izzo thank you
so um got in touch with us uh and and
she she said look I've got your book we
hadn't made a film and and she got
involved in the audiobook doing some of
the music for it and we became friends
and then it just seemed very natural
that she would do the score for the film
and and she's such a brilliant writer
and and very humble she would she kind
of tolerated me
um ringing her in the middle of the sort
of night with tunes that I thought I
would just put a file singing to my
phone and sent her the file and you know
even for my bath and and she would
somehow two days later return by Alchemy
my little grumbly noises into music so
we she was extraordinary and was very
easy to work with an incredibly connect
did emotionally with the film yeah if
that makes sense
wonderful thank you so much and
congratulations thank you
[Applause]